long time been one that says that the QE
program would be open-ended and that we
would be able to adjust it in response
to macroeconomic developments this is a
serious macroeconomic development you
have seen the possibility of
slow growth globally in other parts of
the worlds but I think there is no
reasons for panic or alarm no matter how
hard it tries and no matter how fast it
heals the U.S will face headwinds coming
from abroad the global economy is
slowing you really would not expect the
US to be doing you know to be completely
immune to these bad developments and we
are not on a that solid a basis here so
here we are six years after Lehman cell
still very fragile